-Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a hot crowd.
Guys, I hope everyone's
having a good fall/summer/sauna.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, here in New York City,
the temperature was up
in the high 70s.
Yeah, apparently, we turned
the clocks back an hour
and the calendar by four months.
[ Laughter ]
Usually when you hear "November"
and "mid 70s,"
it's about every candidate
running for president.
[ Laughter ]
Well, speaking of New York City,
this weekend was
the New York City Marathon.
And congrats to any of the
runners out there watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anyone in the audience
run the marathon?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey!
Congratulations.
You had a lot of support
out there --
people handing out water,
Gatorade, bananas, I saw.
I saw a lot of people
with signs,
some signs
I've never seen before.
It's kind of odd.
I took some pictures.
Take a look at this.
This one said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Then there was this one.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Why would you --
And finally,
I saw this one that said...
[ Laughter ]
You know that's not --
Doesn't help anyone.
-I think he knows.
-Let's get to some news.
Big week in politics,
'cause tomorrow is Election Day.
Yep, as we speak, Instagram is
being flooded with two things --
marathon medals
and "I voted" stickers.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the midterms are tomorrow,
which means
you're gonna see a lot of people
walking around with their
"I voted" stickers.
And this year, there's actually
a bunch of voting stickers
to choose from.
For instance, there's the...
[ Laughter ]
Next, there's...
Next up...
[ Laughter ]
Next, there's...
And finally...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Yeah, but it --
[ Both laugh ]
Speaking of midterms,
on Saturday, President Biden,
former president Obama,
and former president Trump
were all campaigning in
Pennsylvania at the same time.
'Cause there's no better way
to win over voters
than by shutting down every
highway in the entire state.
[ Laughter ]
And during his rally
in Pennsylvania,
people were talking about
how Trump came up
with a new nickname for
Florida governor Ron DeSantis.
Listen to this.
-We're winning big, big, big
in the Republican Party
for the nomination.
Trump at 71%.
Ron DeSanctimonious at 10%.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
"Ron DeSanctimonious."
[ Laughter ]
Trump doesn't even know
what that means.
He thought he was casting
a Harry Potter spell on him.
He was like,
"Ron Expecto DeSanctimonius."
[ Laughter ]
"Expecto Sanctimonius!
Ron.
I should've just went
with Ron Weasley.
That was right there.
Why didn't I do --"
[ Laughter ]
Well, with
the midterm elections tomorrow,
there's not much time left
to learn about the candidates,
so we thought we'd help you out
by showing you
all of their
campaign ads at once.
It's time for a "Campaign Cram."
Here we go.
♪♪
-Hi.
-Hello.
-Hey.
-I'm running for...Congress.
Because...in this country,
we...make breakfast.
-And...I shot my...mom...
for no good reason at all.
It was sneaky...
but...I don't care.
She was a...racist,
and...I am...damn proud of it.
So...for some reason,
I approve this message.
♪♪
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
Make the right choice.
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, tomorrow,
several states will vote
on recreational marijuana
legalization.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And politicians
on both sides of the aisle
are speaking out about it.
Here, check out what some of
them are trying to say here.
First up, Congressman
Michael Cloud said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congressman Ted Budd said...
Up next,
Senator Tom Cotton said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congressman
Jared Huffman said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congressman Colin Allred said...
[ Laughter ]
Congresswoman Anna Eshoo said...
Congressman Don Bacon said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Don...
-He didn't understand.
Then Congressman
Dan Newhouse said...
[ Laughter ]
Congressman Barry Moore said...
And, finally,
Senator Roy Blunt said...
Yeah, there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys see everyone's talking
about Elon Musk
taking over Twitter,
and now a bunch of people
have been tweeting
under the name Elon Musk.
[ Laughter ]
So they're saying stuff
that he wouldn't normally say.
Now Elon is threatening
to ban impersonation accounts
that don't label themselves
as parody.
Of course, nobody knows
whether Elon Musk said that
or if it was
from a parody account.
[ Laughter ]
Sounds right.
Hey, I want to say
congratulations to
the Houston Astros on winning
the 2022 World Series.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a big -- It's big
for Astros star pitcher
Justin Verlander.
He's almost 40,
just won
his second championship,
and he's married
to a supermodel.
Tom Brady was like,
[voice breaking]
"Congratulations."
[ Laughter ]
I heard that more than
50 students in Texas
may have to retake their SATs
after the test sheets
flew out of a UPS truck.
[ Audience groans ]
Students should've known
this was going to happen
because one of the questions
on the test was,
"If a UPS truck is driving
at 50 miles per hour
with the trunk open..."
[ Laughter ]
"And another UPS --"
Get this -- a JCPenney in
Pennsylvania had to be
closed temporarily
after a deer entered the store
and got into a dressing room.
[ Laughter ]
That story, again --
JCPenney is so empty,
it's actually
being reclaimed by nature.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Get out.
Get out.
My place.
Get out."
[ Chuckles ]
Well, listen to this --
a New York fugitive
who had been on the run
for almost a year
was just caught at Disney World.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, they caught him
right before he crossed the
international border into Epcot.
[ Laughter ]